[Musique]
un roe n'a pas d'amis droit est entourée
que d'adversaires un nouveau chapitre de
ma vie s'est ouvert
souvenez vous à quoi j'ai passé ma
jeunesse dans l'ivresse lé plaisir
je suis le roi que la prudence soit on
guide rouge et j'ai vu aussi la soif de
pouvoir dont ils sont d'animer j'ai
besoin de mon tour et donne en qui je
peux me fier je suis venu parce que tu
es mon ami je vais venir avec toi
sachez que serait gouverné par un roi
d'une tout autre nature
la france monarque
ils étaient les ennemis de mon père ils
ne sont pas les miens les cris de vos
hommes
la nuit je serai bercé par les sanglots
vous renverserait ce roi henry 5
d'angleterre que vous sous-estimez temps
je suis prêt pour ce qui nous attend
nature de la guerre des trains si
meurtrière rebelles c'est ainsi que la
paix est forgé
éprouvez un sentiment d'accomplissement
cette famille ici pour moi
roi d'angleterre êtes-vous inquiet avec
moi
je sens déjà le fardeau de la couronne
que je porte
[Musique]
il ya quelque chose dans l'air quelque
chose de mauvais cap reçu désobéissants
je t'ai vu coller des affiches pour
retrouver ton frère je peux t'aider dans
ta tête tu crois que si j'avais besoin
des jeux viendront clochard comme toi je
m'appelle ob je peux donner du pouvoir
pour retrouver ton frère mieux foutu
être deux habitants non mais j'ai besoin
de toi vite en voiture tourne tout ça tu
peux pas lui faire confiance
tu as toi je te fais confiance
ça contrôleurs au vent n'ont prononcé
gratuit on ferait rien que je fais pas
[Musique]
c'est toi moi c'est comme une drogue
c'est officiel
[Musique]
ob se laissera pas faire
ouah ouah ouah
dans quels coins du monde deux stars
vont elles se retrouver à la rencontre
de qui elle ne le découvriront qu'une
fois dans l'avion qui les emmènera pour
se rencontrent au bout du bout du monde
spécial noël c'est normal que j'ai pas
de ceinture je te prête la mienne mais
il est complètement en trombe
[Applaudissements]
la règle namurois du grand reporter
c'est d'avoir toujours sur soi son
passeport 50 dans leur art liquide est
la pénicilline bien au sec et en plus sa
pelote passion
[Musique]
elle est
c'est un affront à pau lors de la ronde
[Musique]
marianne me plaît dans son comté
si je pouvais enlevé mon sac à dos là je
m'amuserai oscars je suis agatha 2
[Musique]
ah c'est beau l'amour cet âge là tu lui
a rien dit ah non ne révèle jamais son
secret
[Musique]
il
ne ressemble pas ce que tu crois pas ce
que ça veut dire c'est ma vie je te
signal
oui tout est possible car
tu es l'homme sans gravité
je suis un homme libre
comme ça que ça marche ce cas
tu as besoin de quelqu'un qui s'occupe
de toi
tall petit tente vol dans le ciel
l'homme sans gravité s'est envolé
[Musique]
3la vieux temps
m
je
le testeur je ne sais plus
st
ouah
[Musique]
st
ouais ouais
est ce
[Musique]
appel aux émotions
il le sera
m
et c'est bon
ouais ouais
[Musique]
nous sommes prêts pour vous un geste et
c'est le jour du jubilé qui promet
d'être aussi éprouvant que le jour de
son couronnement
voici 25 ans le jour comme aujourd'hui
posez vous la question depuis que je
suis sur le trône caisse réellement
c'est faux
[Musique]
le pays est en faillite notre sécurité
nationale et roland la volonté du peuple
a changé si cet homme gagne aujourd'hui
il voudra de chasse et nous pensons plus
la paix ne durera pas indéfiniment
je suis devenue reine c'était un grand
pays regardez le maintenant tout ce que
j'ai fait c'est regarder le royaume uni
s'effondrer vous n'avez pas le droit de
travailler et ne s'est effondré que si
nous admettons qu'il s'est effondré
c'est ainsi la monarchie nous
replanterons les fissures
nous y sommes
la soeur aînée est la soeur cadette
numéro un et numéro 2 qui est nommé roi
toi il le sait en plus oui je pense
qu'elle sait
si vous me permettez deux petits cancers
ne jamais fermer la porte au véritable
amour
et le second
méfiez vous de votre famille ils sont
bien intentionnés non il ne le sent pas
chacun jouera le rôle qui lui est
attribué
suis-je écouter dans cette famille
quelqu'un sait qui je suis ce que je
suis non
la colère et le ressentiment peuvent
s'accumuler pendant accepte d'être news
chacun de nous a dû faire des sacrifices
et à des oubliés qu'ils
ce n'est pas un choix c'est un devoir
vos deux tonnes
g